[موسيقى]
حسنًا للاحتفال بمرور 60 عامًا على عقد جيمس بوند
كريستيز بيعًا خيريًا
لبعض أدوات وأزياء 007 الشهيرة ،
يتضمن المزاد عناصر
تعكس كل من الممثلين الستة الذين
لعبوا دور بوند ، معظم التذكارات
تأتي من الفيلم في أي وقت من الأوقات  للموت ،
بما في ذلك سيارة Aston Martin DB5 المثيرة ،
إنها واحدة من ثماني نسخ متماثلة من Aston Martin
Rock تم صنعها خصيصًا من
أجل أي وقت للموت وتستخدم في Matera في
موقع في إيطاليا لمشاهدة مشهد المطاردة
هناك ، لذا فهي واحدة من السيارات المثيرة
التي بها  بعض الأدوات الموجودة عليها أيضًا ، لذا
نعم سيارة خاصة جدًا
، المزاد المباشر يوم الأربعاء عن طريق
الدعوة فقط ، هناك أيضًا مزاد على الإنترنت
مفتوح حتى يوم جيمس بوند
في الخامس من أكتوبر ، وهو تاريخ أول
فيلم تم عرضه لأول مرة
في
عام 1962 ، اسم مسابقة Pop Quiz جميع جيمس بوند الستة
ممثلين